cilly à d'autres créatures dans
l'univers elles vont peut-être découvrir
les beatles pour son 50e anniversaire
la nasa en effet décidé de diffuser vers
le cosmos un titre du célèbre groupe et
elle a bien sûr choisi across the
universe la transmission a commencé à
zéro heure gmt et il paraît que ça danse
là haut jean françois feer et
les beatles et l'espace c'est une
vieille histoire déjà leur département
sur terre on les considère comme des
eaux venues mais de quelle planète
viennent si ces quatre garçons qui
déclenche l'hystérie partout où il passe
les humains ont fait un triomphe qu'en
penseront les petits bonshommes verts
les apports les beatles se lance à la
conquête de l'espace depuis cette nuit
la nasa diffusant le cosmos l'un de
leurs titres le bien nommé across the
universe en français à travers l'univers
voici l'hymne pacifique propulsé à près
de 300 mille kilomètres seconde
destination l'étoile polaire à plus de 4
millions de milliards de kilomètres
cette chanson symbolise toutes les
valeurs de la nasa la découverte et le
partage des connaissances
en fait un petit cadeau à nos voisins de
constellation pour célébrer les 50 ans
de l'agencé spatiale américaine paul
mccartney qui avait déjà donné un
concert dans l'espace en 2005 transmet
je cite tout ces infections aux
extraterrestres le message devrait leur
parvenir dans 430 année